[Musica]
[Applauso]
Potrei cominciare da qua
ho 20 anni e se mi volto un attimo
all'indietro mi vedo ancora fra i banchi
di scuola alle prese con interrogazioni
compiti in classe e tanti tanti
rimproveri poi ritorna in me e mi vedo
sul palco di questo splendido teatro
chiamato ad esporre una mia riflessione
su un tema alto importante Forse
superiore alle mie capacità e
possibilità
Blind l'impossibilità di vedere
l'incapacità di guardare quando ho
ricevuto questo invito mi è parso chiaro
sin da subito che avevo due possibilità
la prima declinare l'invito ed era una
cosa più semplice è la seconda accettare
l'invito ed espormi senza rete ed era la
cosa più difficile per carattere mi
piacciono le sfide Quindi eccomi qua
bisogna dire che dobbiamo partire prima
di arrivare al tema da chi sono cosa ho
fatto cosa faccio e soprattutto perché
lo faccio
sono nato e ho vissuto a Noto cittadina
della Sicilia sud orientale facente
parte delle otto città tardo barocche
dichiarate sito UNESCO quindi una città
d'arte e sono cresciuto all'interno del
laboratorio di Restauri di suppellettili
lignee e doratura dei miei genitori in
mezzo a statue mobili cornici Arredi di
ogni tipo è anche materiali di ogni tipo
per un bambino il miglior parco giochi
ma non finisce qua i miei appassionati
del loro lavoro hanno sempre inteso le
loro vacanze non come momento di relax
da passare questo io al mare che
peraltro dista 4 km da Noto O sui Boschi
dell'Etna Ma come occasione compulsiva
dico io ecco questi qua sono i miei per
andare a frequentare tutti quei posti
che avessero a che fare con artistico
l'antiquariato E comunque L'arte in
generale ed io chiaramente sempre al
seguito
quello dell'infanzia è un periodo molto
difficile perché un genitore può mettere
nel sacco del proprio figlio quel che
vuole quel che può è nel mio hanno messo
tutta sta roba qua hanno rischiato molto
lo so perché potevano incontrare anche
la crisi di rigetto come quando durante
uno dei loro numerosissimi tour de force
hanno rinunciato alla visita a Lecce per
portarmi allo Zoo Safari di Fasano
in mezzo a scimmie pappagalli giraffe
dicevano tra di loro molto convinti
anche il bambino e i suoi diritti
va bene e anche se secondo queste
modalità abbiamo visitato oltre le mete
classiche anche gli angoli più sperduti
della mia isola che custodiscono
bellezze insospettabili destinate
sicuramente all'oblio meta preferita era
il Borgo di Castelbuono e i Borghi
medievali facenti parte del Parco delle
Madonie in provincia di Palermo possiamo
trovare a pochi chilometri di distanza
mentre turistiche come Cefalù conosciuta
e rinomate e poi paesini come Pollina e
di snello che sono pressoché sconosciuti
e privi di flusso turistico
e diciamo che da questa esperienza Io ho
maturato un concetto importantissimo
quanto la promozione la valorizzazione
la salvaguardia dei beni culturali siano
importanti per attrarre l'interesse del
Turista incidere sulle sue decisioni
generando ricchezza per il territorio
evitando altresì il suo spopolamento
vedevo sempre i miei genitori alla
ricerca di quella bellezza che puoi
trovare tanto nella cappella Sistina
quanto nel concio di chiave di
un'abitazione e oggi lo capisco meglio
quell'oro desiderio di bellezza che
tentavano di trasmettere anche a me
stimolando i miei occhi la mia mente e
il mio cuore a guardare più in
profondità a guardare oltre
andando avanti su questa strada poi loro
fotografavano tutto e rientro a casa
riguardavano le foto e io scoprivo
dettagli di che non me ne ero
minimamente accorto ho scoperto così il
potere creativo e selettivo della
fotografia
un'osservazione A questo punto se noi
visitiamo una chiesa per tutto il tempo
che ci aggrada possiamo esser certi di
aver visto voi per le condizioni di luce
o per la prospettiva o per la ricchezza
dell'apparato decorativo meno del 10%
dell'olio Romana presente in quel luogo
e questo ci può fare affermare senza
timore di esagerare che il già grande
patrimonio artistico Nazionale può
essere moltiplicato per un fattore 10 il
che accresce nella stessa proporzione la
responsabilità che abbiamo noi nei suoi
confronti verso la sua salvaguardia e
valorizzazione e come se ci mancassero 9
Dio su 10 è come se fossimo quasi ciechi
andando avanti su questa strada poi io
ho scoperto la telecamera quindi la foto
in movimento la bellezza di scrivere con
la luce
è un mondo di possibilità nuove che mi
si aprivano davanti
poi due anni fa l'evento che ha cambiato
la vita un po' di tutti la pandemia i
nostri governanti decidono di chiudere
l'Italia Ed eccoci rinchiusi dentro le
nostre camere privati di quei diritti
che per un giovane sono fondamentali
il diritto alla scuola in presenza il
diritto allo svago e la socialità il
diritto allo sport il diritto
all'accesso ai luoghi della cultura
c'era di che deprimersi E appunto
molti giovani dentro la depressione ci
sono effettivamente Caduti e ci stavano
ci stavo per cadere anche io Se non ci
fossero stati i video a salvarmi ho
capito sin da subito che i video erano
l'arma giusta per sconfiggere questo
stato d'animo negativo e di essere
qualcosa di utile per me e anche per gli
altri ma dovevo trovare il modo per
uscire di casa
e per non impazzire così provai a
chiedere al sindaco di Noto se ci fosse
la possibilità di fare un video durante
la quarantena che documentasse questo
questo periodo eccezionale un video di
Noto durante il lockdown
e lui me lo ricordo così schizzai subito
fuori di casa alle prime luci dell'alba
desiderose di vedere noto con occhi
diversi e Rimasi folgorato dalla forza
della sua bellezza vedevo il duomo i
palazzi nobiliari il municipio che
riemergevano dal buio e si offrivano
alla luce e mentre
riprendevo mi accorgevo di avere un
privilegio ovvero di vedere quello che
gli altri non potevano vedere in quel
momento e di avere la responsabilità di
essere gli occhi degli altri
andando avanti su questa strada poi il
video mi ha aperto le porte ad una
collaborazione con l'amministrazione
comunale all'interno dell'ufficio
turismo dove mi occupavo della
promozione turistica sui social
principalmente su Instagram sul profilo
Instagram
e mi resi conto di quanto le
amministrazioni siano indietro in questo
tipo di comunicazione che può creare
circuiti economici virtuosi
così decisi di utilizzare una
funzionalità appena lanciata dalla dalla
piattaforma Instagram ovvero
Cosa sono i reels
sono dei video multimediali della durata
media di 15 secondi possono arrivare
anche a 60 che si possono realizzare
tranquillamente con i cellulari e che se
strutturati e realizzati opportunamente
possono essere accattivanti soprattutto
ai giovani che hanno una bassissima
soglia dell'attenzione anche io e
quindi io mi impegnai questi qua sono
alcuni grilli che faccio nel pubblico
nel mio profilo Mi impegnai pressoché
quotidianamente nella realizzazione di
pubblicazione di questi Reel nella
pagina del comune e questo fu una
palestra per i miei occhi che
allenandosi costantemente
vedevano un'altra Noto
questa live sin da subito che questi
Reel fatti sulla pagina del comune
generavano dei bei numeri in termini di
like follower condivisioni D'altronde
come diceva Head Edgar Degas L'arte non
è ciò che vedi Ma ciò che fai vedere
andando avanti poi sono dovuto ritornare
a Roma dove studiavo cinema all'itis
Rossellini e
il lockdown si era finito ma la pandemia
con tutte le restrizioni dovute alla
pandemia c'erano ancora
e sentivo di me che c'era questo grande
è stato d'animo negativo che non
riuscivo a scacciare
e pescando nel sacco in cui i miei
avevano messo tanta roba dentro
trovai lo strumento per combattere
questo stato d'animo questo strumento
era L'arte è Roma come la mia Sicilia
Nest ricca
così incominciai a camminare
freneticamente per Roma entrato
dappertutto chiese musei Palazzi
desideroso di inebriarmi di bellezza e
no dai sin da subito che questa questa
terapia funzionava le giornate
miglioravano l'umore si ricostituiva
e questo fu importantissimo
provai a condividere alcuni di questi
momenti magici anche nei social Ma
stavolta non sulla pagina del Comune ma
nella mia pagina
è magia delle magie il messaggio
dell'arte Il potere dell'arte
corrispondeva ad un'esigenza diffusa i
video da me pubblicati andranno subito
virali generando numeri abbastanza
grossi
vedevo che l'arte proposta così non solo
appagava il desiderio di arte ma
stimolava il desiderio di arte il
desiderio di aprire gli occhi all'arte
anche quando tutto si fa più buio
aprire gli occhi all'arte
ti dà la possibilità di accedere ai
valori che rendono piena e Vera la vita
Tutto ciò può essere un balsamo per
l'Anima una terapia dolce e rigenerante
questo al momento è la mia Mission
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]